[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMY: Welcome Helen
here at Google today.
[APPLAUSE]
HELEN ZIA: Thank you.
Thanks to all of you.
Thank you for taking
time to have me here,
and thank you to the
Google Asian Network
for bringing me here today.
I am an author.
As Amy said, I've been an
activist for a long time.
In fact, I was an activist
before I became a journalist.
And I thought I'd just spend
a couple of moments talking
about how I got from there to
here with my new book coming
out, "The Last Boat
Out of Shanghai:
The Epic Story of the Chinese
Who Fled Mao's Revolution."
And so I'm the
daughter of immigrants,
as she said, from China.
My parents came
to the US as part
of this diaspora
and exodus that I am
writing about in my new book.
But so I was born and
raised in New Jersey.
And I'm just curious
here among all of you.
Anybody from New Jersey?
Oh my god.
One other person who isn't
ashamed to admit he's
from New Jersey.
Maybe there are some there
in the live stream world too.
But so at the time
that I was growing up,
there were so few
Asians in America
that it was as though when
my family walked into a store
anywhere, it would be like
every head in the room
would turn, and look in
unison, and with that look.
Not like, hey, welcome,
but instead, it would be,
what are you doing
here in my America?
And just that feeling of
always being an alien.
And we talk about aliens
today, but it was really
like being an alien from Mars.
And that look,
especially when you
think about the 1950s,
and 1960s, and 1970s,
every war that was fought was
against people in East Asia.
So as a kid, when we
would go to the movies,
there would be that defining
crescendo in a war movie,
where it was like, oh,
the Americans are winning,
and we are going to kill
them, kill them, kill them.
And the "them"
look just like us,
so when the lights came
up in the movie theater,
we'd be with our little friends.
And it'd be like,
oh, OK, are you
Japanese, Korean, Chinese,
spies, or Vietnamese?
And so I grew up with
a sense of that there
were a lot of assumptions
of who was Asian,
and it didn't match anything
I knew about my family at all.
So I grew up with that
sense of, do I fit here,
or don't I fit here?
And so when the civil rights
movement was happening,
a time of great
movements of equality
for people of color,
for African-Americans,
for women and
women's liberation.
The gay rights movement
was beginning then,
and of course, the anti-war
movement and peace movement.
Those were all things
that spoke to me.
And so even though as
an Asian-American girl,
I didn't see a lot of people
like me at all in the media,
because we were totally
invisible except as aliens
from Mars, or as the enemy.
I really wanted to be
part of those movements.
So as soon as I was
around the age of many
of you or somewhat
younger, in college,
that was where I wanted to be.
I wanted to be part
of making a change.
And I have to say today--
and not just America,
but globally--
there really is
that sense of change
to people wanting
to make a difference
and seeing that things
are not going so well.
Not just here in this
country, but elsewhere,
and that we can do better.
And so that was what
the movement was then.
It really was a youth
movement, honestly.
All of those
movements I mentioned,
they were spearheaded
by young people.
And the thing about
it, though, there
wasn't a lot of voice
about Asian-Americans.
It was the beginning of an
Asian-American movement.
And I wanted to be part of
that for the first time,
meeting people
who kind of looked
like me, who shared the
idea that we didn't have
to be second-class citizens,
or constant foreigners
in the country we were born in.
I was always told go
back where you came from.
But I'd have to say
I'm from New Jersey,
and I really don't
want to go back there.
Thank you.
But, of course, we know that
that is not what they meant.
And so I also had a great
curiosity about China.
That's where they
wanted me to go back to.
I had never been there.
And so I became an activist.
My whole goal as a young
person was to get to college.
But then once I got
to college, what next?
And I had no idea.
And as the daughter
of immigrants,
there were only a few
options that I was aware of.
I didn't know what i-banking is.
I still don't, but I
hate investment banking.
[LAUGHTER]
And so to me, it was either,
what, doctor, lawyer, teacher,
or business.
And I was a very shy girl.
Nothing was expected of me,
and so I never spoke up.
And I went to medical school.
That was the only one I thought.
And I ended up quitting
medical school,
because once I got there,
I realized this is totally
the wrong thing for me.
And it was by a
very circuitous way
that I ended up going
to Detroit, Michigan,
after being a
construction laborer,
after I quit medical school,
and then got a job in a factory
at Chrysler
Corporation in Detroit.
And it was there that I realized
what I really wanted to do
is write about the stories
that were completely unseen.
And these weren't
Asian-American stories.
I was in Detroit.
It's mostly African-American,
and working-class white,
and Arab-American people.
But that's where I started
out as a journalist,
spent a whole career
writing about many things,
most of which were not
about Asian-Americans.
So at a certain point, I just
really felt-- you know what?
I've been saving stories
all my life of things
that other people
should know about this,
other people should know about
why being born in America
makes you an American citizen.
That was a Chinese-American
who fought that all the way
to the Supreme Court in 1898.
Everybody who's born
in this country who
can declare themselves a
citizen owes their gratitude
to Chinese-Americans in
San Francisco for that.
And nobody knows it.
So there were so many
things that I had saved,
and I thought people
should know these things.
And that's when I wrote my first
book, Asian-American Dreams:
The Emergence of
an American People.
And as I continued
writing books and stories,
there were just so many other
stories that haunted me.
And one of those
stories was about what
I call a forgotten
exodus, a time of people
fleeing a country, because
they feared the revolution.
They might not have
known what communism was,
but they feared what
was going to happen.
And none of the places
were more magical in China
than Shanghai, compared with
New York, London, Paris,
and Berlin, and Shanghai.
And Shanghai was only behind
New York in terms of population,
six million people in Shanghai.
Albert Einstein, Charlie
Chaplin, George Bernard Shaw,
and Eugene O'Neill; any number
of writers and intellectuals
from all over the world.
If they wanted to go somewhere
in Asia, it would be Shanghai.
That's where the intellectual
heart of Asia was at the time.
And that's where a
vast number of people
fled, because they feared
what was going to happen.
They didn't really know.
It's just they feared.
And so it's a story about
refugees, about exiles,
about people who
didn't know what
was going to happen
to themselves,
but more important to their
families, to their children.
And today we're in a
global refugee crisis, 70
million or so refugees
all over the world.
It's in the news
every day about people
who carry their babies
for 1,000 miles,
not knowing whether
they're going
to get tear gassed
at the end of it,
or have their babies ripped from
their arms, which unfortunately
is happening.
But the thing about it is
this 70-year-old exodus,
which right now, it's
the 70th anniversary.
May actually was the month that
the People's Liberation Army
marched into Shanghai.
And so 70 years ago,
this month was when
this exodus hit full steam.
And so I thought I
wanted to write about it,
because there's not a
single book, dissertation,
or master's thesis on
this topic in English
anywhere in the world.
And I know, because
I hunted for it.
And in Chinese, there are
about three or four books--
maybe today, four.
When I was researching,
only three.
They're in Chinese.
They're all in
Taiwan, and they're
written from the experience
of fleeing to Taiwan.
Well, this diaspora
fled everywhere.
Just like diasporas today,
people go wherever they can.
And so this is the
only book about it.
And I'm just really
thrilled to be
able to sit here today,
and talk about it,
and talk about these
things with all of you.
So I think I'm going to be
in conversation with Amy
and so we can--
I have no idea exactly what
you're going to ask me,
so we can get into it.
AMY: Yes.
And what I love about
what you just shared
is it's clear that there
is a thread of storytelling
that you employ throughout
the entire course
of your career in your life.
I'd love for you to
start off by just
talking about what you feel
the power of storytelling is.
I was reading the book.
There were so many
powerful stories.
The one about your
mother I've read.
I've heard recently
about how you even
found out about that
story, about your mother.
And so talk a little bit
more about what that power is
for you on storytelling.
HELEN ZIA: So I've been
a writer and a journalist
for a long time.
And some of those writings have
been fairly straight forward.
I did this research on A, B, C.
This happened chronologically.
And then other ones have
been about people's lives
and what happened to them.
And the thing about it
is-- and some of you
may know more about just the
neurophysiological pathways
about it.
But human beings, we connect.
We want to connect.
We're social beings,
and the way we connect
is not through data,
and facts, and figures.
The connection is
emotional, and that's
through people's stories.
And it doesn't matter
whether those stories
are about people
from 1,000 years ago,
or 70 years ago, or today.
It's all about what happened to
them, and that's storytelling.
And so the way I
connected with this book
was through a story, the
story about our mother.
I don't know if you want me
to share with that story.
AMY: Please, yeah,
for those out there
who aren't familiar about--
HELEN ZIA: So I had known
about this title, Last Boat out
of Shanghai.
In a way, it's a metaphor,
but people talk about it.
If you talk about anybody of
a certain age, World War II
generation age,
or Korean War age,
growing up as children
or young people
during these 1940s,
1950s period,
they will tell you if
they are Chinese and left
China in those days.
My family left on the
last boat out of Shanghai.
We left on the last
plane, the last train.
We walked, we swam to Hong Kong.
Those are the stories,
and they're all
about being the last ones.
And so I knew this
just intellectually.
And I always wondered,
well, what does that mean?
What is that sense of panic?
What would drive you, any of
us, to leave the wonderful--
the jobs we have, the
comfortable homes,
the communities,
the people we love.
And we only have three tickets
to go, who will we take?
all of those things,
what was that about?
But it wasn't until I heard
a story, and as it turns out,
it was from my own mother
when she was in her 70s.
And I was already in my 50s.
I had already written two books
and spent a career as a writer,
as a journalist.
And I think you grow up asking
your parents, or grandparents,
your family members, what was
life like when you were a kid?
And my mother would always
say, oh, that was wartime,
a bad memory.
And she would
never say anything.
And then you grow up
thinking, well, they're
never going to tell me, or
maybe there's nothing to tell.
And it wasn't until
that I was having dinner
with my mother at
full grown adult.
And I just said, oh, mom
too bad you can't tell me
what life was like for you
as a kid growing up in China.
And that night she said,
all right, you want to know.
I'll tell you.
And you could have knocked
me over with a chopstick.
And I wind down, and
she put hers down.
And she began to tell me about
being an abandoned girl when
she was 6 years old, that
her father had taken her
on a special trip
that she thought
was going to be just
such a wonderful thing.
And instead, he took her to
a strange place and left her.
From that point, it was a story
of the war with Japan begins.
World War II for China
lasted eight years.
She's a child growing
up in wartime China.
She ends up in Shanghai,
is abandoned again,
and makes her way
through a city--
a huge city that was
under wartime occupation
by a terrible memory and a
terrible enemy, and somehow
makes her way to come
to the United States
on the last boat
out of Shanghai.
So she tells me the
story, and I was so--
of course, my
whole world changed
hearing my mother's story.
But at some point, I wanted
to know other people's stories
too to be able to put my
mother's life in a context.
And I began interviewing other
people, finding other people,
doing more than 100
interviews, and with people who
had survived this.
So the stories I
got were amazing,
and that's how I
thought if I'm going
to tell the story of history.
History can be a
recitation of facts,
or it can be made
personal so that you're
reading about people's
lives 70 years ago.
But how to make that real
so people feel like that
could be somebody I know?
What if that was
me, what would I do?
And that's the power of stories.
AMY: Yeah, absolutely.
I think what I found
just so compelling
throughout the whole
book is that as you said,
the stories feel both personal
and universal at the same time.
There are a lot of very
real-world implications today
for these stories.
I know you said that
you spent so much time
interviewing hundreds
of people, and you
landed on four just
incredibly powerful stories.
How did you land on
these four specific ones?
Obviously, the
one you don't want
it being about your mother.
HELEN ZIA: Well, this
book took me 12 years.
Part of it is because
it's such a dynamic, one
of the most tumultuous
periods of the 20th century.
The changes going on in
the world after World War
II, and the revolution in China,
and the complete realignment
with the Cold War going on, the
communist bloc as they called
it, and the countries
like the United States
that were the former
Allied country.
And so there was a lot
going on to capture that.
But so these individuals living
through that time, their lives
were frankly pretty much
of a mess in many ways.
They were living in
total uncertainty.
It was like living with
tectonic shifts under your feet
all the time, except they were
global geopolitical changes.
And where do we go?
What do we do?
And so interviewing
more than 100 people
and hearing their stories, some
of it has been the writer part,
the craft part kicks in.
And you think, how am I
going to tell this story?
It's their stories,
but it's also
a history I want to encompass.
So it has to be people who not
only have, in almost all cases,
several dramatic
stories to tell,
but the memories that were quite
detailed that could take me
from their childhoods,
to their teenage-hoods,
their young adult times,
the college times,
going across the world and
landing in different places.
And then being able
to describe all that.
So that narrowed it down,
but also some diversity.
There were two girls and
two boys I focused on.
I was very clear.
You know, war and occupation
and flight is gendered too.
It's a different experience.
I mean, it was terrible for
all, but a different experience
being a boy and a girl.
I wanted different
class backgrounds.
The reputation of
people from Shanghai
is that they're all rich.
Well, guess what.
A million people, they're not.
And in fact, there was a
huge income gap there too.
The vast majority of people in
Shanghai were incredibly poor.
So I didn't want them to
all be educated and wealthy.
So I have one who
is the daughter
of a nationalist, a
Kuomintang, the side that
lost the war, the revolution.
So there was politics
involved too.
One was the son
of a collaborator.
His father sided with
the enemy, with Japan.
And we know how that war ended.
So you can imagine, their life
when Japan was occupying China
was amazing.
And then as soon as the
surrender documents,
they were out on the street.
And so that was partly it.
But they each had
amazing memories.
And people actually
say, wow, how could you
remember such things when
you were such a small child?
But in some cases, one was
maybe three or four years old.
And she saw Japanese
soldiers come
into their house in the
middle of the night,
point a bayonet and a
sword at their mother,
ask for their IDs, and make
a move toward her mother.
And then her mother stood
tall and stared them down,
and they left.
Now you would remember
every detail of that
if that was your mother,
no matter how old.
And so they remembered
these things,
because they were such
incredibly not just
dramatic-- in many
cases traumatic things.
And they remembered what
was the color of the room.
They remember what people
said to each other,
the sense of that.
They remembered their feelings.
And so these are
people who had to also
be open enough and
reflective enough to tell me,
what was it like when
your father was in prison,
and you thought that he
might be executed at any day?
And to have them
tell me those things.
Now, they didn't
open up their lives,
especially terribly
frightening or tragic things,
until I had maybe met with
them over a period of six
years already, to trust me
with these kind of stories.
My mother, it took her 70 years
before she could tell anybody.
She had kept this a secret.
And a lot of the
people I talked to,
they would just tell
me about their lives.
And the average age of
the people I interviewed
was about 80 years old.
And at some point,
I would say, that's
an incredible story
you just told me
of what you had lived
through and survived.
Does your family know this?
And they would say,
no, I don't think so.
Well, what about your kids?
And their kids would
be grown adults, right?
I don't think they're
so interested.
No.
And then I would
say, no, I really
think you should
tell your family.
I think they would
really want to know.
And when people experience
things like having to flee--
or you can imagine
what it's like to be
on the border of the
United States today
and being separated
from your children
or being one of
those children living
in cages on a hard floor.
I mean, you're not
going to tell about that
and open up your
emotions, because it
might take years and
decades before you can even
share that or put it together
or not fear being judged.
Or, in the case of my
mother, as an abandoned girl,
I think she feared being
stigmatized, being made fun of.
Kids did when she was a child.
And so it takes time.
I mean, we know that
Holocaust survivors,
it might have been their
grandchildren who found out.
Or people who experienced
the incarceration
as Japanese-Americans
during World War II.
It was the
grandchildren who first
began to find these things out.
Their kids had no idea.
And so one of the lessons was--
I mean, it was serendipity
that I just that night
said, oh, Mom, too bad you can't
tell me this at a point where
she was ready to tell me.
And had I not said that, she
might not have ever told me.
She might have been one of those
other people who said, oh, I
don't think my family cares.
They don't ask.
So one of the lessons
is don't give up.
If they say, oh, I don't
want to talk about it now.
They might not say "now."
But in your head, say,
OK, maybe some other time.
AMY: Yeah.
I think that really
resonates for me.
I am the daughter of immigrants,
refugees from Vietnam
who fled after the war.
And I think as I grow
older, little by little,
I feel like they're beginning
to open up and tell me
more things.
They have so much
trauma around it.
And I can understand the
hardships and challenges
and difficulties
they went through.
I think you chronicle that here.
You chronicle the challenges,
hardship, discrimination
that people fleeing their
countries were facing.
I'd love for you to
talk a little bit more
about what was it like hearing
these stories of just very
real hardship?
And how did that make you
think about its implications
for today?
HELEN ZIA: There
were times when I
was hearing stories that
brought tears to my eyes
as well as who was
telling me the story.
But the fact was,
we were sitting,
whether it was in Hong
Kong or Taiwan or in China
or here in the US.
And they had made it to
their 70s, 80s, or even 90s.
And some of them had
lived through many, many--
I also interviewed people
who remained in China too.
And so they had
experienced the revolution,
the many political movements,
the cultural revolution.
So every story had pain.
But they also had joy
to them, because they
survived the hardships.
They also had
inspiration and things
that we could connect to.
So that was the part that
I really had to hold on to.
And any writer or anybody
working on a project that
takes a long time--
and especially 12
years as a writer,
you're kind of by
yourself doing this.
There are times when you think,
why am I still doing this?
Is anybody going to care
about this except me?
Does this really matter?
And so the part of
it is, those stories
made me feel like I have a
responsibility to the people
who told me, who
opened up their hearts
and told me their stories.
So I have a
responsibility to them
to honor their
stories, to tell it
in a way that they're entrusting
me, the truth of their lives.
And then there's the
broader picture too,
because I wanted
to put it together
as a history of
something that happened
to millions of people
that is completely
forgotten except by them.
And then when you multiply
it by their children,
their grandchildren,
their families,
we're talking about
multiple millions of people
having experienced
something that other people
in other times, fleeing
Vietnam, the last helicopter out
of Saigon--
I mean, all of those
things-- or the last boat
or leaving Syria
today and putting
your kids who can't
swim on a rubber raft
into the Mediterranean.
And you don't know whether
your kids are going to survive,
but what you assume is
that you stay, they won't.
And that's why they leave.
And so then being able to make
a connection to that and say,
well, you know what?
There's a larger story here.
Because that's why people flee.
Or that's why people immigrate.
And this country, being a
country of largely immigrants--
and I say largely, because
unless you are Native American,
everybody's people came
from somewhere else.
And one of the lessons of
this book or any exodus
is that if families
are doing OK--
I don't mean doing well.
I mean if they're doing
OK, and they can make it,
they don't leave.
They stay.
Who would want to
leave their families,
their homes, everything
that they fought and love?
They only leave if they have to.
And that applied
to the pilgrims.
It applied to every migration
from Germany, from Italy,
from everywhere
else in the world.
You asked me about the
power of storytelling.
If people could connect
to their own stories,
no matter how many
generations back,
and really identify
how hard that
was for their own grandparents,
great-grandparents, relatives,
ancestors, that might
create a little bit more
empathy for the people who
are going through this today.
And that's what it was like.
I mean, writing it, feeling
that you take these stories--
you take some of that
energy from people.
And you feel like, I
have a responsibility
to do something with that.
So even hearing
stories that were hard,
it just made me feel
like, I have to tell this.
People need to know.
It can't just get forgotten
to the dustbin of history.
AMY: What I'm hearing is
just this idea of connecting
to our own history and the
importance of connection
to our histories.
Speaking of May, it's API
Heritage Month as of yesterday.
One thing I love about
"Last Boat Out of Shanghai"
in addition to "Asian
American Dreams," which
was published in
2000 is that I think
you do a really amazing job of
melding both the personal story
but also with the actual
chronicled history
and specific historical
incidents that
have happened throughout
Asian-American history.
Can you talk a little bit more
about "Asian American Dreams"
and what you wanted readers
to get out of it in terms
of the different
modes of history
and how that should
shape and inform
Asian-American identities
and actions and beyond?
HELEN ZIA: Well, sure.
"Asian American Dreams"
was my first book.
And I always knew--
because I had collected
stories in the day
before internet and so forth.
I mean, all you had were
the newspaper or magazine
clippings.
And I was a dedicated
news junkie.
I would read everything.
And I would collect
stories, because I
knew there was
something more I wanted
to find out behind the story
and to tell it in a fuller way.
Having grown up as an
Asian-American daughter
of immigrants, I just
never saw our stories.
Because I was Asian-American, I
would hear about these stories.
The killing of Vincent
Chin for example,
the hate crime that happened
in Detroit when I was there.
This is something that some
Asian-Americans may not know.
But even being Asian in
America, our stories are--
I feel like we're
robbed of our history,
that these are things
that are just not--
they're not in movies.
They're not in television.
OK, there may be some
things now in the internet
if you know where
to look for them.
So I reached a point where I
really felt that I don't know
when it is I'm--
what I'm waiting for
to try to write a book.
But finally I reached the
point of saying, you know what?
In my lifetime I've seen so many
changes for Asians in America.
Our population has
grown tremendously
from when I was that Martian
alien invader as a child who
was completely invisible.
And even in those days, Bruce
Lee, the great Bruce Lee,
was only a sidekick in TV.
He could never be
the champion himself.
And so that was the way it was.
And I just felt like
these are completely
missing the real stories
and the real contributions
and the real
experiences of people
of Asian descent in America.
And this idea that
we all just came here
to take advantage,
take the benefits,
work somewhere, take
the money, and run--
which is a continuing, even
today, idea, even possibly
at companies like Google.
Are we really people
who belong in America?
What is our contribution?
That was missing.
And that's what made
me feel like finally,
I have to tell
some of this story.
Because pretty much
I was just fed up.
And what was going
on in the news was--
at the time, when I was
writing this in the mid-1990s
was saying that
every Asian-American
who ever participated
in this democracy
and donated $10 to a
presidential campaign,
that they were conduits to the
People's Republic of China,
even if they were from Taiwan,
the Philippines, Vietnam,
India, Sri Lanka.
It didn't matter.
They would all, as Asians, be
potential spies and conduits
to China.
Well, what could be more
ridiculous than that?
But it was out there, and it
was in the headlines every day.
And that's what made me
feel like, you know what?
I have to write about this.
And I have to show
the real story
behind what we've been
doing in this country
and why everybody born here
is an American citizen, how
the separate-but-equal
laws were overturned
as unconstitutional in the 1800s
because of Asians in America,
and all of those things.
So that's why I wrote that book.
And I feel like today
we're still in that space.
And it's painful to watch.
Because the media--
and I include
the internet and internet
content to that--
so often goes to the
lowest common denominator.
If everybody can jump on
this and agree with this, OK.
It gets the most hits.
This must be true.
When in fact, there are
things we have to dig for.
We have to look for it,
because it's not there.
In a way, we have to be
intelligent not just consumers,
but we have to be
detectives on our own.
And in doing that, in finding
nuggets of history that, wow,
I didn't know that.
This affects me.
I'm a citizen because
I was born here.
Which, by the way,
there are some people
trying to change that, even
after 1898 when the Supreme
Court decided that.
We need to be informed about it.
So even in today's
space, I think we all
have a responsibility to try
to learn these things that have
happened and pay attention.
Stay woke.
AMY: I learned about the
murder of Vincent Chin
when I was in third grade.
I remember my
third grade teacher
asking us to write
an essay about--
I forget what the essay
topic was actually.
But I remember my
third grade teacher
asking us to write an essay.
And the thing I had chosen
to write my essay about
was the murder of
Vincent Chin and you.
And what was shocking
to me is when
I wrote this essay in third
grade, no one around me
knew who he was.
Not my family, not
my friends, nobody
around me, no one at school.
This was the first time
that a lot of people
had been hearing about it.
This was the first time that
I had been hearing about it.
So for you, what really drew
you to Vincent Chin's case?
And why should this case matter
to Asian-Americans today?
HELEN ZIA: Well, so I was
in Detroit at the time
that Vincent Chin was killed.
And I was just beginning
my life as a journalist.
I had been an activist
up until then.
I wasn't really clear what
I was going to be doing.
But I was in Detroit.
I had been working at a Chrysler
stamping plant, in a factory.
And why was I there?
It was really because
friends of mine
had said, if you
really want to know
about the heartland of America
and really be an organizer
and think about change and
social change in America,
you should go to the heartland.
And so I thought, oh, good idea.
And being young,
I went to Detroit,
not really knowing a soul there.
And so I happened to be working
in Detroit when the entire auto
industry collapsed.
And I know it's hard for,
probably, most people listening
or watching to imagine.
But in the last recession--
nobody wanted to
call it a depression.
That was a depression.
Millions and millions of
people were out of work
and had no idea when
they would have a job.
And these were high-paying jobs.
This is when minimum wage
was about $1.30 an hour.
And working in a car factory,
you were getting $10 an hour.
That would be like minimum
wage today at $15 an hour
if you're lucky
and instead getting
a job that paid $60 an hour.
I mean, imagine what a
difference in your life
it would make.
And so these were people who
were permanently laid off
from jobs that got them not
only a house, a second house,
a summer cottage, two cars,
a recreational vehicle,
all kinds of vacation,
health care, retirement.
All that stuff gone
down the drain.
And what happens when people are
really miserable in a mass way
like that, not knowing?
They start wanting
to find who to blame.
And the finger of blame
ended up on Japan.
Why?
Because the dinosaurs that
Detroit produced in those days
that could get maybe seven or
10 miles a gallon if that--
the competition was either
Volkswagen or Japanese cars,
which could get
more gas mileage.
And gas was so
expensive in those days.
Most people couldn't afford
to drive their cars anymore.
That's why people
lost their jobs.
And so Japan was blamed and
anybody who looked Japanese.
So anybody with
an East Asian face
was considered to be
part of the enemy.
And remember I had talked
about the wars preceding.
So the whole idea that you could
have been the enemy from Japan,
from Vietnam, from
Korea, from China,
and now the Japanese cars.
So if you were
Asian, East Asian,
walking down the
street in Detroit,
you knew you could be attacked.
I mean, the climate
was so thick.
The only thing I can
compare it to today
was right after 9/11
and the Islamophobia
that we still have in
this country today,
and, sadly, so many killings
even in recent days.
But at that time,
a young man named
Vincent Chin, who was
Chinese, not Japanese,
happened to be out
for his bachelor
party, the All-American
bachelor party.
And two auto workers, two white
auto workers, saw him and--
can I use bad language?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AMY: Yes.
OK.
We got the thumbs-up.
HELEN ZIA: --saw him at a strip
bar for his bachelor party
and said, it's because
of you motherfuckers
that we're out of work.
And you can imagine what kind
of reaction that would draw.
And anyway, that turned
into a fight that
spilled out into the streets.
And these two white
autoworkers chased
Vincent Chin and his friend--
only his Chinese friend.
There were other
non-Chinese friends
that they didn't bother with.
But the two Chinese
then were chased
through the streets of Detroit.
Vincent tripped.
One grabbed him.
The other had the baseball
bat and bashed his brains out
into the street.
And so that would have
been terrible enough,
but it was witnessed by probably
more than a hundred people.
Because it was just a
busy night that night.
And two were off-duty
police officers.
And so there was no
question that they
had killed Vincent Chin
and said what they said.
But when it finally came
out to getting sentenced,
the sentencing judge
said, oh, you're
not the kind of men
who should go to jail.
You're clean-cut.
And he didn't say
clean-cut white guys,
but that was the implication
in a city like Detroit.
You're not the kind of men
we should send to jail.
So he gave them probation.
And so for beating another man's
brains out into the street,
they were given probation.
And that created an uproar.
But why it was so important
was because at the time,
in the 1980s, the Asian-American
community was very separate.
It was each ethnic community.
There wasn't something
called Asian-American.
It was you're Chinese-American,
Vietnamese-American,
Korean-American,
Japanese-American,
and Filipino-American.
And those were the major Asian
ethnicities in the Detroit area
at the time.
But it was a minuscule number.
And the Asian-American
community came together,
calling itself
Asian-American, to say
this was a violation of
Vincent Chin's civil rights,
and these men should be
punished for doing that.
And it became a national
civil rights movement
with the improbable epicenter
in Detroit, Michigan
of all places.
But it was something that
every Asian person in America
felt, because whether you
were in the Midwest or not,
you really felt
like people hate me.
They're looking at me because
this country is in a depression
right now.
And it's because of MFs like
you that we're out of work
or that we're suffering
or that our economy is bad
or that I can't get a mortgage
anymore or all of those things.
And so it was the moment
that Asian-Americans really
started, in a mass way, talking
about civil rights, race
in America, where
Asian-American people fit
into a dialogue around
race, which up until then
had been completely
either black or white.
And Asians were
like, what is this?
They were the Martians from
Mars, the aliens from Mars
like I was as a kid.
Like who are you?
What are you doing here?
Where do you fit?
You have nothing
to say about race.
You're not black,
and you're not white.
And that was the moment.
And that's why it's so
important in many ways.
There have been many other hate
crimes against Asian-Americans,
sadly to say, since then.
And today we seem to
have an epidemic of hate
crimes against so many people.
But it was a time where
Asian-Americans were--
it's like, step up now and raise
your voices as a community.
AMY: That idea of step up
now and raise your voice
as a community is
something I think
we've been talking a lot
about in Asian Google network,
this idea of solidarity.
I think it's one
of the strongest
themes that comes through
in "Asian American Dreams."
You talk a lot about the
solidarity of our community
as it relates to how we came
together on Vincent Chin.
Then you talk about
times when our community
didn't come together.
You also talk about times when
our community has stood up
for other communities,
other communities
of color in particular, and
times when we haven't at all.
And so can you talk
a little bit more
about why does solidarity
within our own community
and also with other
marginalized communities matter?
HELEN ZIA: Well,
solidarity, connectedness,
sharing each other's stories,
having a feeling or common bond
as human beings, let alone
as people in one country,
I mean, that's what makes us
move forward as a civilization.
It's what separates us from
other animals and species,
this ability to do that
and to build on that.
And so it's vitally important.
And the flip side of that
is keeping people divided.
And we are at a time today
where divisiveness and pitting
one group of people
against another
is being honed to a fine
art and blasted every day,
not only on TV and movies, but
every tweet that comes out.
There's so many of them that
are just filled with venom
and hate that it's all you can
do to just say, well, OK, let
me protect my little
cocoon and my little one
square foot of space
that I'm standing on.
But in fact, if we only
exist for ourselves--
and that applies to everybody,
not just Asian-Americans,
but everybody.
If we only think of our
own self-interest, that's
the easiest and surest way
to be manipulated to say,
well, Asian-Americans,
you all go to Harvard.
Why should you care
about a lawsuit that's
happening at Harvard right now?
Well, in fact, the vast
majority of Asian-Americans--
and studies show this--
go to community colleges and
state colleges, not even UCs,
and face the same issues
that every everybody else--
the economic choice of can
I make it through college,
or do I need to help
support my family,
and all of those things.
But this myth has become to
not just separate, for example,
Asian-Americans apart from
other people of color or people
of conscience but that--
to me, it's like a bad
rerun in another way of when
I was growing up as a kid
when we were so completely
invisible, nobody saw us.
Now it's a way of saying,
well, you're all doing so well,
you're actually almost
honorary white people.
And so you're invisible
too, because you blend in
with the scenery.
And the idea of blending
in with the scenery,
it's counter to the whole
idea of-- as humans,
we want to be recognized.
As people in a world,
we want to be--
and that's the power
of stories too.
It's being acknowledged.
I have humanity.
So do you.
So does everybody.
But do we see each other,
and do we hear each other?
And that only happens
when we're connected
and we can share
with each other.
I mean share that common
interest with each other
to do something that
will benefit all of us
as a society or a community
or as a workplace.
I mean, that's why the
connectedness is so important.
And that's why I wanted to
tell all of these stories,
because I think that's a
way to pull people together.
AMY: Thank you.
So we'll open it up to
audience questions now.
AUDIENCE: We have a
question on the [INAUDIBLE]
I'll go ahead and read for you.
AMY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: This question
says, "setting aside
history and cultural roots, in
your opinion, how important is
it to grow up with
mastering mother tongue
other than English?
What's the impact of speaking
a language other than English
to assimilation?
If my kids aren't interested
in my native language,
should I lose sleep over it?"
HELEN ZIA: Oh.
Language.
AMY: Yes.
HELEN ZIA: So when I was a kid
growing up during the McCarthy
period when people from
Asia and especially China
were all viewed as potential
spies or a fifth column,
meriting a fifth column
against the United States,
my father said to my
mother, don't speak Chinese
to the children.
Because he knew and he
experienced discrimination just
in the way he spoke.
And my father spoke
perfect English,
but he did have an accent.
And as a kid, I
saw him ridiculed.
And it was painful.
But my father made
that decision.
And as an adult, I have
regretted it every day.
So I grew up as a typical
monolingual American,
knowing only English
as my culture
and then having to study other
languages, but not Chinese.
And it wasn't until I was in
college that I actually took
a couple of Chinese classes.
So I can speak at a
level of, I think,
about a 2- or 3-year-old.
But not enough to
have a conversation
and not enough to read.
If your child speaks another
language or two or three,
each language, I think, just
multiplies their ability
to be somebody meaningful,
have meaningful understanding
and connectedness in this world.
It multiplies them
tenfold each time.
And for me, I know
not even being
able to speak or read
Chinese, that cuts me off
from an entire culture.
It makes it so-- in doing
my interviews, I did not--
my interviews had
to be in English.
I did have a translator.
I did have other people helping.
But I knew I was
missing nuances.
Why did they pick this
word and not that word?
And if kids are unwilling--
I mean, of course, we all know.
For kids, it's like, I want
to be like everybody else.
I want to go play.
What, are you going to make me
study this language that nobody
among my friends speaks?
One day they will thank you.
I'm told that's true for
musical instruments too.
But it's really
true for language.
Just the ability to
travel in this world
and be in other
places, it's critical.
And I'm sure in a
workplace like Google,
being able to know
other languages--
a multinational company
that has viewers and people
all over the world,
the more languages
you speak and the more
you can connect there,
I'm sure it's an asset.
So I wish my father
had never said that
to my mother every day.
AUDIENCE: As a proud
queer Asian-American,
I'm interested to hear your
story or biggest challenge
you have as a lesbian
Asian-American.
HELEN ZIA: So as a proud
queer person of color,
Asian-American lesbian,
I mean, the first thing
is it's assumed that we're not.
I mean I have been told,
especially whether it's Asian,
Latino, African-American
communities, being queer
is a white thing.
Why are you-- you don't exist.
The entire continent of Asia,
there are no gay people.
What?
And that in itself is
hilarious to think about.
Even China recognizes
at this point
that they have queer people.
And so the challenge has
been, number one, knowing
that you can pass and
kind of be invisible.
And layer that on being an
invisible Asian-American
and also as a woman,
being walked on
or stepped on by
people who are like,
oh, you're female,
what do you matter?
I don't want to be invisible.
I think that's harmful.
I don't think anybody really
wants to be invisible.
And so the biggest
challenge, I think,
is being seen completely
as a full human being.
And so there was
a time in my life
when I didn't feel
confident about being out.
And I think that's true for
every queer, gay, lesbian, bi,
trans person to be understood
and to be seen fully.
And so anyway, you go
through this time of
should I tell people.
And the hardest
part was actually
being able to tell my
family, because these
are the people that know
you and love you, you hope,
as well as my community.
So I actually went out--
I went through a period
of time that I wrote about
in "Asian American Dreams"
where I was already an activist.
I was already
very, very involved
with communities of color,
including Asian-American ones.
And I had what I call
my lesbian trial, where
I hadn't come out yet.
I didn't even know--
I was at that point
where I wasn't sure.
Now they call it
questioning or whatever,
where you're just not
sure of your identity
in every full way.
And so I was real involved
with feminist movements.
And in these women's
organizations,
there were some lesbians.
But in the way that
a lot of-- sort
of in the misogynist way
that feminism is disparaged,
it was like oh, if you're a
feminist, you're all lesbians.
And therefore, the
300 women who would
come to our citywide meetings
in Boston must all be lesbians.
So my organizing
community that I was in,
which was Asian and
African-American,
called me to a meeting one day.
And it was, like,
a space like this.
And when I got to
the meeting, they
were sitting in a semicircle.
They were all there.
And it's like, oh,
everybody's here.
And they said,
yeah, you sit here.
And it's like, oh in the center?
And it soon became
very clear that I
was the topic of the meeting.
And one by one, the head of the
Asian community organization,
the collective, he
said, well, you're
here because we've noticed
that you're hanging
around a lot of lesbians.
And we need to know whether
you're a lesbian or not.
Because we could not
have you in our community
as part of our organizing,
because you would bring
discredit to us.
And the head of the
African-American collective
says, that's right.
In our black community,
there are no gay people.
And he didn't use the word gay.
But there are none.
And it's a symptom of white
petty Bourgeois decadence.
And so if you are a
lesbian, we wouldn't
want to have anything to do
with you or any other Asian.
So I was sort of like, oh,
everybody's going to be--
so, Helen, tell us,
are you a lesbian?
And I sat there thinking, well,
I don't have a membership card.
I didn't get the toaster oven.
I've never held
hands with a girl.
I don't know.
But I knew it was
clear if I said yes
that I was going to get
excommunicated from this
community that I was part of.
It was my spiritual
home at that point.
And so, tell us, Helen,
are you a lesbian?
And I said no, I'm not.
And it was at that point, I
stepped back into the closet
and slammed the door shut.
So for me, it was, I
guess I would have to say,
quite a circuitous path
to eventually coming out.
And it was shortly after that
I actually moved to Detroit,
because one other reason was I
just felt so ashamed that I had
closed the door not
only on myself but all
of these feminist women's
liberation activists too.
I mean, how could I face them
when I basically had said--
So that was another reason
I thought, OK, a good time
to get out of Dodge
and go to Detroit,
where I pretty much stayed
in the closet for quite
a long time, I think, for me.
But anyway, I mean,
as things happen,
life never travels in a
straight line, so to speak.
But it goes in zigzags.
And so that was a
big zigzag for me.
But it was also why I
ended up in Detroit.
And so I was in Detroit.
And that's where I found
this Asian-American community
and became part of a national
civil rights campaign
but then eventually found my
way to come out as a lesbian.
And I married.
I've been married three times.
And I have to point out,
all to the same woman,
because marriage has been
such a contested fight
to be able to even be
married to the person
that I've been
with for 27 years.
And is still in jeopardy
because of the way
the Supreme Court may turn out.
And so anyway, there
are all these things.
There is no right
that's fully guaranteed.
And that's why we all
have to be active.
And that's why, as an
Asian-American queer person,
I need to be out there too
so that people can't say,
oh, Asian people don't
have anybody who's queer.
And that was a slogan that
came out of the HIV epidemic.
Come out.
If you can come out, you must,
because silence equals death.
And I think that slogan is
true for every community,
every underrepresented
community,
every marginalized community.
Silence is death.
We have to show who we
are as full human beings,
because we don't, nobody else
is going to do it for us.
And so I think those are the--
a continuing challenge.
But thank you for that question.
AMY: Thank you so much
for your question.
I believe we are at time.
But it went by very quickly.
But thank you so much, Helen,
for being here in conversation
with us today.
We really appreciate
your time and just
feel so honored
to hear from you.
I don't know if you
can tell, but you
are my shero, one of them.
So this was a huge
honor for me as well.
Thank you, everyone.
HELEN ZIA: Well, thank you all.
And thank you, Asian
Google Network.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.